let's bring you some breaking news now
uh on the fallout from these latest
claims of downing street parties let's
bring in our deputy political editor sam
coats who's in westminster tell us more
sam
yougov have surveyed over 5000 people
today about what they think about boris
johnson's position let's bring you the
results 56
say that boris johnson should resign
should resign in a poll uh scene uh by
sky news today 27 say he should remain
uh in his role so that's the no boris
johnson shouldn't resign on your screen
now and 17 percent uh think uh that they
don't know at the moment but over 50
percent think that boris johnson should
go now if we just give you some context
uh if you look back about six weeks ago
uh that gap uh that lead for uh the
number thinking that boys johnson should
resign was far far lower uh so the 56
figure that you're looking now is up
about eight uh points uh uh on november
2021 uh 31 at that point
thought he should stay uh and it shows
that the partygate affair the uh uh
turbulence in downing street about that
and about covid and about the cost of
living is having a real impact uh on
views on boris johnson's premiership
when you dig down into the numbers it
looks like tories are increasingly upset
as well people who voted tory but about
a third of them want boris johnson uh to
go and as we saw at the weekend tory
members increasingly wondering whether
or not uh somebody like rishi sunak or
liz trust might not only be better at
running the country but also uh beat
boris johnson uh at the
ballot beat the labour party better than
boris johnson at the ballot box there is
a lot of turmoil inside the conservative
party at the moment in the last few
moments one former cabinet minister has
messaged to say boris johnson's going to
have to have a different approach to
government if he wants to survive but
i'm not sure he has the capacity or the
flexibility to do that but i don't think
he can wait until the local elections in
may before he does anything there are
some initiating a conversation uh about
whether or not after may is a time to
replace boris johnson before the summer
recess that's what happened of course to
theresa may a couple of years ago so
that conversation has started in parts
of the conservative party you've heard
the anger there from the scottish tory
leader douglas ross suggesting uh that
figures must go if they are found to
have broken the rules there's an ongoing
inquiry by a senior civil servant at the
moment
and lots of evidence that will
complicate uh boris johnson's uh
position so boris johnson's uh future at
the moment unclear with that large
figure uh 56 percent uh saying uh that
he should resign
designer one thing uh resignations are
another sam there's no sign that boris
johnson feels that he should resign he
won't even at the moment answer whether
he went to a party or not we are waiting
for the results of the this
investigation as we keep being reminded
we shouldn't pre-judge it um but there
doesn't seem to be any sentiment coming
from downing street that boris johnson
is anywhere close to considering his
position
well you've got a couple of options if
you're prime minister in a spot like
this and one of them uh is to front up
the problems that you've caused to give
a big apology to uh say to the nation
look i got some of these judgment calls
wrong they weren't parties but we were
having alcohol i can see why that was uh
a mistake we were in unusual times
that's one option open to number 10.
they are not choosing that option
instead they are pressing button b that
is the tough it out option
they are refusing to make any
concessions they are refusing to really
acknowledge the problem they are simply
saying it's up to this independent civil
servant and she is pretty independent to
be fair uh to come to her own uh
decision about whether or not there were
parties whether or not they broke the
rules whether or not they broke the law
there is a complication this afternoon
however sarah jane which is you've got
this inquiry by a senior civil servant
but you've also hovering in the
background got a potential police
inquiry and if the metropolitan police
decide that the weight of evidence is
such that they do have to look at what
went on uh last spring
and launch a formal investigation then
you're going to have to put
the civil service inquiry on hold and
that police investigation might take
many many months so if the police get
involved then the chances of sue grey
the senior official inside government
doing that investigation reporting next
week which is a possibility well that
won't happen it'll all be kicked into
the long grass so if the police do end
up getting involved there will be no
early resolution to this danny street
will have to rely on that we wait for
the inquiries and the police reports for
much much longer than many many tory mps
want
and that could make the wound even
bigger